ja meine lieben freunde habt richtig
gehört es wird nach rio ein neues
projekt geben wann hero endet kann ich
noch nicht sagen aber das neue projekt
wird den namen tragen hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge minecraft
exit auf dem hero server nach der
typischen hundertsten folge gestern für
dich zeigen beschäftigen teilte ein
bisschen mit dem hausbau und der luca
den hashtag auf twitter komplett
vergessen mensch management der männer
ganz kurz hier twitter.com search
contractor themen an hashtag kann so
twittern jetzt gehen wir hier auf den
hashtag drauf mit bart mama was hier so
für dem sind weil ich mir so
da das ist gut was würdest du machen
wenn du 5000 auf der straße finden
würdest du niemand raus finden wird dass
du es geklaut hast also geklaut in
anführungsstrichen also erst mal ich
wäre glaube ich erstmal diesen charakter
hier zu bauen weil der mich ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen aufregender inmitten
der stadt hier sind und krater
wunderschön selbstverständlich nicht
aber wir haben natürlich genau um das
ganze zu bewerkstelligen weil unsere
kiste aufgeräumt sind mehr oder weniger
so fackeln brauche ich auch weil ich
kein verkappter unten
ach ich will da unten nicht so ein loch
lassen aber irgendwie nicht als auch
nicht so eine höhle ist komme ich setze
jetzt einfach fackeln hin da unten und
dann ja braucht nur noch sechs aber gut
dass heute glaube ich reichen zur
beleuchtung das hat sich so viel
passiert also was wir erst mal zur
hundertsten folge gestern ja ich weiß es
war relativ schlechte schauspieler die
binde auch kein guter schauspieler
leonardo dicaprio
ich reiße mich dann immer zusammen und
denke ich bin gut aber kriegt dann doch
kein keinen oscar nein spaß will mich
hier nicht mit irgendwem gleich stellen
oder so ich kann einfach die
schauspieler ich habe auch gesagt dass
das pack ich wollte erst gar keine
wäsche machen oder nachts mehr so
kurzzeitig
ihr könnt ja eigentlich doch mal machen
ich dachte ich wäre im trading können
sich eigentlich noch mal machen und zwar
habe ich dann einfach gedacht okay macht
soll das halt ich finde die idee
eigentlich ganz gut
eine umsetzung als vielleicht ein
bisschen nur noch 15 aber dafür dass es
wirklich in zwei stunden glaube ich
entstanden ist geht das eigentlich sogar
noch ich hoffe euch als trotzdem
gefallen als ich dann so kommentare
gelesen habe wie ja das finde ich auch
voll cool
minecraft hero mit dir macht richtig
spaß und so richtig geiles video
da denke ich mir also ich finds selbst
richtig kacke dieses wort ist peschl
eigentlich in die chemie schäme mich da
so ein bisschen für mir tun die leute
leid die so schreiben sie ja finde ich
richtig gut weil ich glaube die wollen
oder so damit zeigt dass wir eigentlich
kacke aber wem unter den mal auf also
ihr braucht mir letztlich zu
versprechungen geben dies das könnte
ruhig schreiben eine scheiße fand er
selber ein bisschen blöd war auch
traurig eigentlich hat sich jetzt so was
gemacht habe als 100 folgen special
aber für mich ist halt 100 zahl wie
jeder andere auch und da werde ich jetzt
keinen großen hackmack hier irgendwie
drum machen also das halt einfach zu 110
folge dann jetzt eben zur frage kurz und
danach möchte ich ihn noch über ein
kleines thema reden hier sind auch schon
wieder 19 andere fragen angekommen das
ist richtig geil auf twitter die
beteiligung von euch also bei twitter
werden echt fast alle fragen genommen
twitter.com search von crafter wenn ihr
wirklich wollte dass ich über themen
spreche das ist nicht als irgendwie
höflich krieg für follower geld nein
kriegt nix für nur es immer den
kommentaren hier bei youtube so viele
themen und ich kann da halt nicht immer
drauf eingehen deswegen beitritt dass es
nicht einfacher und ja so dass zum thema
twitter
das so ja wenn ich das geld finden würde
bei mir war es mal so dass ich eine uhr
gefunden habe die fand ich mega mega
geil
das war so ein kleines schwarzes hat man
damals hat so getragen hatten braucht
man sich sowas heftig stylisches oder so
etwas eine schwarze schlichte nike und
die hat sogar noch kalender angezeigt da
kommt man so umstellen dass war damals
für uns rechtzeitig und bereich sex oder
sohn 11 12 jahre ist das her und ich
fand die halt mega cool und wollte ich
unbedingt behalten und ich wusste erst
nicht als ich habe dir auf dem schulweg
im schnee gefunden ich wusste erst nicht
dass meine eltern sagen sollen ob ich
hier so einfach behalten sondern darf
mir so nett wie ich bin nie der kleine
luca hier ja ich sag das mal meinen
eltern lieber vielleicht sagen dir etwas
zu da diese ja die uhr gehört nicht de
luca die gehört jemand anderem blabla
und dann dachte ich mir so
aber ich möchte die uhren da meinten die
aber nie stell dir vor du wärst diese
person und das ist anspruch der mich
mittlerweile so mein leben begleitet das
ist ein ganz normaler spruch jeder
andere auch und es war halt einfach war
aber dass ich mir jetzt immer denke wenn
ich ihn mir anstellen denke an diebstahl
stellt euch mal vor ihr wird die person
der er wird das cloud wie man wenn dir
jetzt irgendwie okay wenn man 5000 euro
findet gehören diese 5000 euro
es ist jetzt nicht so dass die bank das
druckt und einfach der transporter das
verloren
der transporter ist so abgeriegelt das
ist ein anderes thema sagen wir mal die
gehirn wirklich einer person dann ist es
halt so dass diese personen sich das
wahrscheinlich gearbeitet hat oder hat
das vielleicht gespart und will sich
davon selbst nie was anderes holen oder
so und ich finde immer so etwas so eine
person dann zu beklauen man kennt quasi
nicht im hintergrund
wenn jetzt ein reicher sack ist und der
da irgendwie eh nur mit atomkraftwerke
und so ein scheiß gebaut hätte wo ich
gerne machen aber es weiß man ja nie und
wenn man erstmal davon ausgeht dass man
geld findet denke ich erst mal daran das
geht vielleicht in dem armen menschen
der das irgendwie gespart hat
mitgenommen hat und vielleicht wollte er
seinem seiner seiner frau die im sterben
liegt blumen kaufen wenn man sich mal so
eine story überlegt man dann dieses geld
klaut und er geht dann zum beispiel man
klaut und dieses geld und läuft dann weg
und er
läuft dann nach fünf minuten zurück
sieht dann oh ich hab das geld
vernünftig bestimmt noch irgendwo auf
dem weg und dann liegt das geld einfach
nicht mehr da ist es echt schon traurig
und wenn man sich dann aber nicht das
vielleicht an die frau gestorben ist
weil sie dann die blumen nicht gesehen
hat und die liebe hätte sie sonst
zusammengehalten keine ahnung total
komische sachen halt ich weiß nicht ich
finde diebstahl richtig richtig kacke
also ich würde diese 5000 euro wenig
5000 euro finden würdest du schon eine
hohe menge
ich würde es trotzdem zurückgeben also
ich weiß nicht wie das geregelt ist wenn
wenig 5000 euro finde wieder dann ist ob
das dann irgendwie so ist und dass man
portal nee das ist nur so ein ob sie ja
ich weiß nicht wie das dann ist also ob
das so ist dass man dann finderlohn
bekommt ich glaube dass cap oder ob sich
da auch jeder melden kann
dabei muss sagen den man muss den ort
sagen wo das gefunden wurde oder
irgendwie sowas keine ahnung wie das
abläuft ich will es auf jeden fall
abgeben auch wenn sich sein liegenden
und ehrliche personen oder kalt es ist
mir egal ich hab was gutes getan und ich
fühle mich besser man hat echt ein gutes
gewissen also ich würde auf jeden fall
zurück bringen und dann alle die jetzt
diese story mit dem mit der uhr weiter
wissen wollen wie es weitergeht die kg
cura abbauen
königin ihr und zwar hab ich halt diese
uhr gefunden und hab das dann meine
eltern gegeben dem fundbüro abgegeben
hat sich auch wirklich ein junge dann
gemeldet der irgendwie 34 jahre älter
als ich da die gefunden hatte er sich
dann voll bei mir bedankt und das coole
war dann dass mir diese familie von dem
jungen
die fand das sonett von mir und ich war
wirklich so traurig dass diese und ich
hatte ich weiß nicht vielleicht hab ich
sogar bei der übergabe geweint ich weiß
nicht wann ich sagen hier die für diese
familie hat mir dann eine neue uhr
gekauft
und genau die gleiche halt und das fand
ich echt mega mega net also ich sags mal
so wenn ihr menschen gutes tut kommt das
gute auch zurück das muss nicht immer so
sein es gibt auch leute die tuning
ganzes leben lang nur gute sachen und
sterben dann irgendwie ohne einmal was
tolles erlebt zu haben
aber
das ist halt einfach das leben aber es
ist halt wirklich so wenn man hättest du
leuten wie im fall mehr erfolg im leben
als wenn man mega kacke zu denen es und
ja das wäre etwa von mir zu diesem thema
vielmehr broich tatsächlich auch gar
nicht zu sagen kann ich auch gar nicht
zu sagen ich brauche ich alle nicht
jahren packt mal ein dickes b block 1
könnte ich mir auch welche holen nach
einem level
aber egal kommen wir zu einem anderen
thema und zwar wird es ein neues projekt
geben
ja meine lieben freunde habt richtig
gehört es wird nach hero ein neues
projekt geben wann hero endet kann ich
noch nicht sagen aber das neue projekt
wird den namen tragen
sag ich nicht darf ich nicht sagen will
was er sah wie gesagt wir hatten letztes
eine besprechung scon fiel zwar genau
gestern abends um acht uhr wo ich erst
mal krass zu spät kam weil ich noch
trainiert und es gab keinen anderen dem
motto die haben sich halt darauf
geeinigt und da waren halt echt nahezu
alle am start komme kam zwei stunden
später glaube ich circa zwei stunden
ich kann mir wieder hier sind allerdings
machen
ich gehe einfach ganz kurz davor soll
ich mir vielleicht noch ein paar
electric stars machen dass ist ein
bisschen schade dass ich quasi noch
electric stoffs brauche da musste ich
einfach mal so richtig weit reisen
electric grete knete grippe war da nix
naja egal also zu dem portal kommen ja
noch sohn christoph in sachen habe ich
eigentlich alle mit oder habe ich hab
ich nicht noch irgendwo im rucksack
beck nee also einschalten
da es noch ein rucksack wo wir das kraft
wenn da jetzt noch so krasse geile
sachen drin wäre als einfach nichts drin
so egal ich nehme einfach mal mit es
wird ein neues projekt geben wie genau
das projekt aussehen wird kann ich euch
jetzt mal ein wenig verraten und
wird es minecraft wenn nein es werden
erstmal grundsätzlich jeder von hero
wird mehr oder weniger dabei seien
ausser man sagt jetzt nämlich wenig
dabei sind aber zurzeit ist es halt so
dass eigentlich jeder dabei sein will
fischer der seit am arsch so ich weiß
nicht wie viel da noch kommen
man kann sich aussuchen ob er mitmacht
oder nicht ist irgendwas wertvolles hier
ein mikrofon habe ich schon
nein was steht denn da oben erscheint
schnauzer du sollst hinkommen und seine
kritik gegeben
es wird er halt erstmal jeder dabei sein
eigentlich und es wird in teams teilen
außerdem kann ich zum motto pack sagen
das ist cool wird ich werde nichts
verraten zum mord pack ich werde wenig
verraten hier damit immer vielleicht ein
bisschen diskutieren könnten kommentar
also ihr könnt ihr einfach über euch
jetzt mal mit meinem electric sda
ihr könnt ja meinen kommentaren so ein
bisschen mit den anderen leuten
diskutieren was ihr denkt wasser
eventuell auf euch zukommen wird
eventuell ist ja der eine oder andere
hat er hat er recht wird willst du denn
hier ich möchte hier die anderen haben
aber sonst was kann ich sonst noch sagen
der tod der tod wird heftig sein und
zwar wenn man stirbt ist man tot man ist
raus wenn man stirbt das hat ja immer
mehr gewandelt im mega projekt was so
wenn man stirbt scheiß drauf einfach
respawn im hegau was so ein tag ab laut
sperre ist auch geil wenn man tot ist
ist man komplett draußen das hat nämlich
auch diesen ganz geile effekt dass man
wenn man quasi stirbt dass man also
nicht wenn man ja wenn man steht dass
man draußen das ist vorbei man
konzentriert sich quasi viel viel mehr
auf jede einzelne handlung die man macht
das heißt so was wie beispielsweise oh
ich hab keine goldene feder dabei ich
gehe trotzdem leben in etwa wenn ich
sterbe hab ich halten tag ab laut
bericht auch alle sachen salt hat darauf
solche situation gibt es halt nicht
man sagt dann zum beispiel wo ich hab
keine goldene feder mit ich geh mal
nicht ein netter weil ich dann eventuell
sterben wird euch hab viel kritik bei
uns ich bräuchte noch bräuchte sechs
damit ich folgen also dann muss ich hier
nicht mehr hin
also es wird auf jeden fall ein paar
coole sachen geben
wir haben auch über ein paar andere
features noch nachgedacht die sind
richtig geil ich sag nur sprach
entfernung mehr sage ich dazu nicht weil
ich da und ich weiß auch dass alles
sagen darf aber sonst es wird auf jeden
fall megageil und ihr könnt euch auf
jeden fall richtig darauf freuen weil es
einfach nur cool wird und ja mehr
bräuchte es auch gar nicht sagen jetzt
jetzt können wir uns aber mal wieder
twitter bieten bieten widmen
herbig slp gibt es infos zum neuen
projekt von die aus habe ich gerade
gegeben
wenn du zwei wünsche bereichert es
welche wären das
was steht noch ohne sich mehr wünsche zu
wünschen
ja das ist nämlich auch also die sache
wenn ich drei wünsche frei hätte würde
ich mir als erstes wünschen tausend
wünsche ihm aber gut das gilt ja diesmal
nicht ich würde auf jeden fall wünschen
dass ich wirklich mit 100 jahren sterben
weil ich will nicht unendlich leben aber
ich will auch ich will quasi mein platz
frei machen im leben aber jetzt ich sage
mal nicht hallo jetzt nicht direkt aber
auch nicht halt so zehn jahre später
bescheid ist alles meine person etwa
erfahrung hier ein heim so jetzt kann
wieder gehen
der unnötige khaki abkommen das kann ich
mal bei cap in die komische dinge tun
in die waffenkammer aber sonst würd ich
mir auf jeden fall gesundheit wünschen
dass ich bis 100 lebe dann möchte ich
jetzt sterben
anthony dass ich einfach sagen kann wann
ich sterben möchte dass ich einfach
sagen okay jetzt möchte ich nicht mehr
leben das dann einfach tot bin dass wir
cool
und mein zweiter wunsch wäre kostenlos
reisen
ich bin ein mensch der sehr gerne reist
und ich will auch wahrscheinlich nach
dem abi nicht direkt studieren was ja
erstmal ein plan war das ändert sich
hoffentlich hab ich ja gesagt sondern
vielleicht auch erst eine weltreise
machen also was heißt weltreise so ein
bisschen halt um die welt reisen weil so
eine chance hat man hat wirklich nur
einmal im leben dass man richtig reisen
kann das also ich werde wahrscheinlich
nach dubai nach neuseeland nach amerika
alle möglichst gibt also im sonnenstudio
bauunternehmer wo man sich das so quasi
ankreuzen kann mehr oder weniger so
jetzt aufs blut drin alter ich ja noch
gar nicht ausgemistet die kisten und da
werde ich dann auf jeden fall versuchen
so etwas zu planen ich brauche die
herzen und wales apple kann ich sogar
schon machen mag jetzt mal einfach so
mache ich das mal so
deswegen kostenlos reisefähigkeit also
dass sich keine kosten übernehmen muss
für flug für autos laien so was alles
dass das wäre echt cool kostenlos reisen
und selbstbestimmter man stirbt findest
du hier langsam langweilig oder macht es
immer noch spaß also mir macht
eigentlich noch spaß ein paar leute
sagen ja bzw
die zuschauer sagen das ja immer dass
das ganze langweilig wird und so ich
finde es gar nicht also ich find bei mir
fängt gerade erst so richtig an weil es
jetzt so mehr auf kommentare antworten
und so das macht richtig spaß bei dieser
twitter sache mit themen schreiben das
macht man ja schon richtig lang habe ich
habe das noch nie so intensiv gemacht
wie bei hero weil man halt auch wenn man
alleine aufnimmt dann hier immer mit ein
paar leuten lagern kann welche
fremdsprachen hast du in der schule also
erstmal muttersprache halt deutsch und
die fremdsprache wonach er fragt
englisch latein und spanisch hatte ich
auch mal ein ja wenn du ein spiel durch
leben könnten welche wäre das ein spiel
durch leben wenn man einfach so
beifahrer ist dabei quasi dann auf jeden
fall prince of persia welche spiele
zeigst du noch außer minecraft zurzeit
nur
fifa und gta und daraufhin die so
flexibel oder kandy crash oder so so
weit wollte ich eigentlich noch machen
ich wollte mal endlich das haus genommen
bis in die häuser bauen und elektrik
sachs brauch ich oder ich geh jetzt
wirklich mal auf reisen
meine lieben freunde damit wir mal
wieder
damit war ich hier mal wieder so ein
bisschen besser bescheid so ein bisschen
eventuell farben gehen können bürger
direkt schneller hier manchmal dimap
falle an damit ich hier gleich schon mal
da sind schon was ist hier schon alles
drauf an breaking drei protection 4
sollte der überall an breaking drei
protection 4 an breaking 1 an breaking
drei protection bekommen makiadi wann
breaking noch drauf das wäre vielleicht
ein bisschen sinnvoller so mache ich am
breaking zwei einfach auf beides
unterschätzt geht müsste eigentlich so
habe ich an breaking an breaking so
protection er dann sollte eigentlich
laufen
ach so da brauche ich jetzt mal einen
mix
biggs war ich dann mein biggs ort ist
das eine fixe ort für freunde des
gepflegten die comedy reisebeginn ich
einfach in der nächsten folge
bingo weil jetzt war das ein bisschen
nicht so frisch dass jetzt am ende der
folge machte hardy ist aber mega voll
die falle
nein was ist das ach so tolle lederjacke
doch was habe ich denn jetzt werden
was hältst du davon dass die gegner
jetzt geld für das einbetten von videos
verlangt also an alle die nicht in der
materie drin
es ist mittlerweile beschlossene sache
glaube ich ist es beschlossene sache ich
weiß nicht ob es beschlossene sache ist
dass die gema geld irgendwie verlangen
will wenn man videos zum beispiel bei
facebook postet oder wenn man die in der
website einbetten oder so das heißt
komplett kommt die industrie geld
bezahlt weil der video-serie einbetten
oder auch netzwerke oder irgendwelche
blogs oder so wenn ich bei facebook auch
so ist ich find's einfach abzockerei die
gema ist eine geld mache
geld mache wow das passt sogar das ist
krass okay und ich verlege hat bis ihr
leben ja weiß nicht finde ich auf jeden
fall nicht so geil ich mag die gema an
sich so gar nicht mal so ein paar sachen
nicht brauche ich nicht geht der tiere
überhaupt runter hallo
lasst euch mal
jetzt oder geht doch nicht die
pohlheimer ag staatsfunktionäre mir doch
egal so klar wie viel scham nicht einmal
bekomme was ist sonst noch so bekam
hofft die idee dich ins mega-projekt zu
tun zu tun ist erstmal tolles werk es
ist ja aus dem gebiss let's play von
simon uhr
das habe ich so eine skype es ist ja aus
dem gebiet let's play von simon und mir
entstanden das heißt sie mann und ich
haben das quasi beschlossen das ist das
mega projekt überhaupt gibt deswegen ich
bin quasi mitgründer des mega praxis
wegen muss dichter als nicht von
irgendwem reingetan 43 neue ergebnisse
legst du noch bei deiner familie oder
würdest du oder wann würdest du
ausziehen
ich lebe noch bei meiner familie ja weil
ich halt auch noch zur schule gehe
ausziehen werde ich also ich mache mein
abi juni dann werde ich erstmal urlaub
machen und schön und dann werde ich ja
wahrscheinlich eine reise machen die
dort acht monate geht er weiß ich nicht
wie das mit youtube laos mit ich weiß
aber noch nicht ob ich diese reise
wirklich antreten werde
hier an hier wie so ein wettkampf ob ich
da wenig anteil gehen werde
oder einfach mit einem mix hat geklaut
das natürlich cool jetzt einfach mal
vier herz zu schaden krasse sache an die
ich glaube aber der der männer noch
funktioniert gerade für mich als ein
anschließen okay vielleicht sterben die
auch einfach jetzt mal oha da krieg so
viel schaden wie ich selbst den gebe das
ist krass er funktioniert doch nicht na
gut egal ich mache jetzt einfach mal
hier hin da bleiben 23 alter eben da
drin und meinem ressort auch oder ist es
da jetzt ist ja auch kacke wer denn
eigentlich muss ich die folge schon
längst beenden
aber ich will halt einfach mal ein
wixforth jetzt mal haben er hat dass
nämlich der hat das derart 121 leben der
pizza ich schieß den einmal abnahme ohne
witz putzt und ich habe direkt krassen
schaden obwohl dort geht sogar noch das
schaffe ich weder generiert sich auch ne
generiert er sich der generiert sich der
pista generiert sich und ich bin halb
tot
leider sollte man biggs dort bald da
manchmal lieber neue sehr große sache
naja gut meine lieben freunde nächste
folge werden wir dann eine reise
antreten schon wieder 14 er frage sich
erstmal über twitter danke an alle
themen folge vorbei waren diesmal echt
mega cool dabei danke herz so
hashtags hero so twittern
sein name hat auch getwittert danke für
die geilen themen ich geh jetzt mal hier
raus ich hoffe euch hat die 110 folge
gefallen ich hoffe euch auch euch hat
diese folge gefallen schreibt meine
kommentare was ihr denkt was mit dem
neuen projekt sein wird was es eventuell
sein wie tyson wird was wir machen
werden schreibt mit themen die
kommentare bei twitter wenn es dieses
mal auch mit themen dabei sein wollt und
natürlich sagen lassen wir wer wir sind
macht gut und scharf